be warned you have just crossed the
threshold into the most hazardous piece
of space real estate in the solar system
at Jupiter's magnetosphere there is
almost nothing that can protect you
that's a kind of a don't enter this zone
at any costs and if you do you better be
prepared to pay in terms of your
electronics you know you are toast
step inside Jupiter's raging magnetic
field and you enter a radiation hot zone
of staggering intensity where incoming
charged particles from the Sun are
whipped into a relativistic frenzy
buffeted by the solar wind
the magnetic Maelstrom streams back
almost as far as the orbit of Saturn the
magnetosphere of Jupiter the largest
thing in the solar system if it were
visible from the earth it would be the
size of the full moon in the sky this
was like a magnet to NASA setting off
for deep space for the first time in the
early 1970s the Pioneer missions were
initially designed to fly the first few
test instruments into the environment
sample how bad the radiation was and oh
by the way let's kind of throw a camera
on there maybe we can get two or three
pictures along the way it's almost like
putting your toe in the water the water
proved deep and deadly but despite
faltering instruments and fuzzy photos
the Pioneer flybys paved the way for the
missions that followed what pioneer told
us was that Jupiter's radiation belts
were even more intense than we had
anticipated and that meant that our next
mission Voyager suddenly went in to
rework real fast to put more shielding
on board shields up captain because we
knew we were going to be getting a lot
of radiation dose
when the space-hardened voyagers 1 & 2
flew past in 1979 on their way to the
outer solar system
Jupiter's great mysteries only deepened
how were these powerful magnetic storms
generated inside a giant ball of gas why
was one moon boiling with volcanoes
while its neighbour remained covered
with ice and what lies beneath
Jupiter's clouds it was Galileo's
mission to investigate